es ist ein ungewöhnlicher anblick rote
amerikanische sumpf krebse bevölkern die
weg im tiergarten mitten in berlin
direkt am brandenburger tor beginnt der
große park wie genau die krebse hierher
kamen ist unklar
vermutlich stammen sie von aquarien
bewohnern ab die jemand hier ausgesetzt
hat seit 2008 10 sorgt klaus hätte dafür
dass die sumpf krebse in den berliner
gewässern nicht überhand nehmen jedes
jahr zwischen ende april und anfang
november bringt er seine reusen aus fünf
jahren sind die kredite ist er ist also
auf wie verändert die krise sogar über
die wege die laufenden
seitdem sind die sumpf krebse zu einer
wahren plage geworden die allesfresser
vermehren sich rasant und bedrohen so
andere arten
außerdem sind sie als träger der
krebspest bekannt auch hier im britzer
garten im süden berlins haben sie sich
ausgebreitet
wir fangen in der woche im tiergarten
und glitzer garten fangen wir ungefähr
70 kilo krebs zusammen rund 70 70 kilo
krebse sind ungefähr 2500 krebse also
das ist für eine ganze menge mit seinem
fang beliefert klaus hätte verschiedene
berliner gastronomen wie das restaurant
fisch frank im westen der stadt
gekochte sumpf krebs entstehen hier
regelmäßig auf der speisekarte
die krebse sind einfach sehr beliebt
weil sie neu sind leute kennen hier nur
die flusskrebse in diesem sumpf krebse
sind ein bisschen anders schmecken
vielleicht klein bisschen süßlicher an
musiker und ist interessant das ging für
durch die presse und jeder möchte
eigentlich mal diesen krebs gegessen
haben die sumpf krebse werden in einem
würzigen gut gekocht in das kochende
wasser kommen ein lorbeerblatt salz
kurkuma und pfeffer rastete karotten und
koriander
anschließend bleiben die krebstiere für
fünf minuten im topf
wenn wir den krebs um den dreht man so
ein bisschen den schwanz raus
und dann kann man von der unterseite den
panzer wegdrücken
dann haben sie nur noch das schwanz
segment oder waren ganz raus und hat das
reine krebsfleisch was man was man essen
kann und in dem fall ist dass mainz die
krebse werden mit salat baguettes und
reserviert
[Musik]
auch in der gehobenen gastronomie sind
die sumpf krebse angekommen wie hier im
messetrubel zins im stadtteil prenzlauer
berg inhaber bands viel bereitet die
krebstiere mit fujitsu einer soße aus
fermentiertem reis wir verwenden
hauptsächlich lokale produkte aus bio
dynamischen und biologischen anbau und
coaching ist eine wirklich gute basis um
diese aromen aufzunehmen und ihnen eine
weitere dimension zu verleihen
doch zunächst werden die sumpf krebse
gedreht die soße braune butter und
zitrone geben dem gericht eine besondere
note wir leben in einem gebiet mit
süßwasserfischen und es gibt nicht viel
kosten tiere in süßwasser die sumpf
krebse sind eigentlich das einzige tier
das man hier bekommt das vielleicht an
ran ehlen oder langusten erinnert rote
amerikanische sumpf krebse in berlin
eine plage die zur delikatesse wurde